des champs à perte de vue dans le nord
ouest du yémen les agriculteurs
s'activent il faut récolter et moudre le
blé avant de l'expédier un peu partout
sur le territoire
une denrée essentielle pour les 30
millions d'habitants est essentielle
mais insuffisante car habituellement le
pays compte aussi sur ses importations
problème elles sont désormais menacés
par la guerre en ukraine
si la guerre entre la russie et
l'ukraine se poursuit le prix du blé
augmentera encore et puis il ya aussi
les prix du pétrole si la hausse
continue les frais de transport bon
également augmenter ça va se répercuter
sur la population
le cren et la russie sont deux gros
exportateur de matières agricoles et
notamment de blé mais avec la guerre ils
ne sont plus en mesure de produire
autant qu'avant
résultat les quantités disponibles
diminuent et leur prix augmente de
pour le moment on trouve de la farine
mais on a peur d'être à court c'est
pourquoi nous demandons aux négociants
d'importer des quantités suffisantes et
nous appelons les autorités concernées à
aider les agriculteurs à cultiver du blé
dans notre pays et essayer d'atteindre
l'autosuffisance 1
la situation est particulièrement
inquiétante pour le yémen car l'économie
du pays est déjà dévastée par sept ans
de guerre civile la population est au
bord de la famine à tel point que selon
l'onu près des deux tiers des habitants
pourraient avoir besoin d'une assistance
alimentaire au cours du deuxième
semestre de l'année